drew barrymore opens up about motherhood
and how it's changed her it's just made
me such a better person the actress was
glowing on Sunday gushing over her
daughter's olive and Frankie they're my
favorite people on the planet fiji spoke
with the 41 year old at the safe kids
event in LA where she got candid about
her girls and how they've impacted her
life I always loved and try to live on
the high road I think you feel best when
you behave or react or will come from
the high road place and my kids have
elevated that for me in a way that is
indescribable and it seems a drew is
taking the high road after splitting
from husband will kopelman earlier this
month she told us why she's chosen to
focus on family and career well I think
it's good to show my kids that I'm
passionate and I have a good work ethic
and that you have to earn you know what
you have in this world but I heard the
greatest quote the other day and and it
sort of changed my life because I think
it sums everything up which is I can't
wait to go to work and I can't wait to
go home love what you do and put your
family first good